Trump was asked about wokeness that's
that word on the right we're all just
beating the hell out of wokeness we hate
wokeness and and that's persuading a lot
of moderates and people in the middle
wokeness has got to end it's gone sick
and I don't like the term well because I
hear woke woke woke you know it's like
just a term that use half the people
can't even Define it they don't know
what it is as is often the case well
everybody is zigging Donald Trump is
zagging the guy is contrarian not just
with the broader culture he's contrarian
even with the right the conservative
movement the Republican party in part we
should expect this because the guy
didn't spend his life in the
conservative movement of the Republican
party and so on this one this is the
easiest softball oh yeah wokeness bad he
says I don't like that term it's kind of
a silly term no one can really Define it
and you know what he's kind of right